foreign
hey what's up everybody what's going on
oh you've got your volume up again every
single time
by default sometimes okay he just like
forgets me would you like yeah when you
reset your tablet just by default puts
it on the middle yeah
um yeah so it's Tuesday today and we're
in this we're still in the Universal
monster kind of GrooVe yeah you know
what I mean and this is a follow-up to
the two that we did about Dracula 1931.
yes this is uh the sequel to The English
Dracula 1931 it's called Dracula's
daughter from 1936 1936 yes five years
later and um a decent sequel a lot
better than the son of Dracula all right
which is the third one yeah Lon Chaney
yeah no but uh this one was a decent
movie I liked it well this one I kind of
feel like this if you're gonna do a
sequel this is kind of like I mean the
way they did with Bride of Frankenstein
too this is like the way to do it right
because it went through like a bunch of
different iterations like what the story
was supposed to be but I think they
settled on a good thing like I think
initially Bella Lugosi was supposed to
be in it like I think they were gonna do
some scenes like set back in the day
like uh kind of like a prequel it's like
a prequel or like exploring his history
and then it was gonna jump ahead to the
present day and I think they had an idea
initially too yeah that would have been
good too but I think they had an idea
also initially that Dracula's daughter
was going to have lived in the castle
like Dracula's castle and then like Van
Helsing would have gone back to the
castle to kill the vampire Brides but
then like found her like she was hiding
someplace else so that was another idea
they were throwing around that'd have
been good but well the thing what
happened with this one but like I said I
think it's good that they just kind of
like I mean Bella Lugosi ended up not
being in it but I think that's okay
because they just went it's still in the
same universe and honestly it's just
like
um the start of it it takes place like
literally like minutes after the first
movie ended you know what I mean like
Van Helsing has just staked Dracula yeah
and then like a few minutes later like
the cops come and be like he gets
accused of murder which is what would
happen in real life because because he's
like yeah I stabbed him he was a vampire
and they're like okay tell us another
one they didn't ever really bring up
what happened to um Renfield because
Renfield was killed yeah that's right he
was throwing off the stairs well he's
Renfield in the Spanish version he's uh
no no he's right now Renfield in the in
the Americans that's right so uh they
never did mention what happened to his
body they would have found that they
would have they would accuse Van Helsing
a kill at him also yeah it's like I cut
I thought that they mentioned it but
maybe they didn't
like because they weren't they were
saying there's like there's two dead
people in there and like one of them has
the stake through the heart they
couldn't accuse him of killing Lucy
because she was already legally dead
yeah they just cut her head off yeah
even though they didn't mention that in
the English language version which we
could which we kept breaking up right
they'd ever like that they just left the
hanging yeah it's funny but uh but yeah
so that's kind of what happened so you
have Van Helsing who I think that guy
that plays Van Helsing
um Edward Van Sloan he was the same guy
that played Van Helsing in the first one
but he's like the only repeating
character which kind of makes sense
because you know it was kind of like
it's it goes in a different direction
slightly but what they were yeah so what
they were gonna do
they initially wanted to because
remember how when they made Nosferatu
back in the 1920s and
um Bram Stoker's Widow
sued them you know and so they wanted to
like destroy all this so you know she's
very sue happy I mean it's you know I
didn't want to like disparage or
anything like that because that was like
you know their intellectual property and
they you know and stuff like that so
they should be compensated for the [ __ ]
but they were kind of worried what they
wanted to do with this one is that
um there was an excised chapter from the
original novel by Bram Stoker and after
he died it was actually published
separately like as a short story which
is called Dracula's guest now they've
actually made that into a film
subsequently but I think that was kind
of like the idea behind this one
initially even though it's if I remember
it's been a long time since I've read
that story but I don't remember this one
having anything really to do with that
story but that was kind of the direction
they were going to go in and then many
people have pointed out especially
because of like the lesbian angle that
comes up in this one which actually I
was surprised they got away with the
[ __ ] they got away with in this movie
and then in 1936 but so a lot of people
have said that there's like a little bit
of a whiff of carmilla in this as well
yeah by Sheridan Le fanu which like I
said if you don't know your horror
literature that's actually older than
Dracula that was published in 1872 and
is probably kind of like the first
lesbian vampire
story like ever written that they know
of you know yes it's not that is not a
modern Trope that was the original no no
yeah it one thing this movie though uh
as far as I know this is the first film
Addison you know not you know not in
literature or anything but the first
film appearance of a reluctant vampire
yeah which is now a very very common
truth Louis was like well Anne Rice was
a big fan of this movie
um and you know she actually
acknowledged I think later on that this
had been influential particularly like I
said in The Reluctant I think I think it
also came from Mama waldi from immacula
too yeah he didn't really want to be a
he didn't want to be a vampire he would
he was he wasn't given the choice yeah
but like I said I guess the same thing
well they don't really specify in this
one because the vampire in this one is
um she's named what was her last name
zeliska solicit yes I think it was yeah
something like that like she so she's a
countess right and I don't think they go
into the specifics of how she exactly
got turned you're led to believe I'm
guessing that Dracula turned her I don't
think he's I don't think she's actually
his biological daughter I thought it
maybe was because he said it was he came
from a family of them
maybe exactly but she was much much
younger than he was so I'm not really
sure how that would have worked out what
do you mean well I think at some point
because didn't when okay like at the
very beginning when Van Helsing has
staked Dracula and is like talking to
the cops about it yeah and then they
asked him like how long has this man
been dead and he says oh about 500 years
which I was like wow yeah that's pretty
funny but yeah there's like so he was
saying he was about 500 years old or
he'd been around for that long yeah
whereas I think later on in the movie
they say that the Countess has only been
dead or only been a vampire for like a
hundred-ish years yeah so he had 400
years he had a lot of time to have a
daughter
right but it's like could he have a
daughter like after he was already
Undead that's what they're how does that
work a stragoy could do it well I know
that but it's I don't I don't really
know I get I mean I guess it doesn't
matter I'm thinking about it too much
but I don't know if it was his
biological daughter if it was just like
somebody if it was just that he like
vampire turned vampires were based on
stragoy all right could
could mate with a living human woman and
give birth to a a living vampire yeah
that's what they're talking about I
think
I think she was born a vampire
that's what I that's that's my take
yeah I mean it's possible
and maybe they die
or maybe you kill them but they come
back to life as an undead vampire she
was Undead she didn't have a but she was
Undead but yeah but she definitely lived
as a as a living person long enough to
reach physical maturity
because she looked to be in her 30s
right yeah I'm imagining yeah she was
she was an adult right she wasn't like a
vampire baby that wasn't a vampire child
which those are in some of the stories
you know yeah
um where they're all going to be a child
forever
like wow that would suck hard from
Interview with the Vampire yeah another
vampire's [ __ ] forbade that you
weren't supposed to do that but well I
thought you did it I mean it didn't give
a [ __ ] if vampires really existed I mean
you could see that that would actually
have to be a rule because yeah that
would be a really shitty thing to do to
somebody well they somebody in the past
had done it before so they knew how it
turned out right and they were like you
can't do that yeah because like I said
that would be [ __ ] up if like you
never grew up you were just a child
forever that would be terrible I think
the explanation interview of the
vampires that they can't survive on
their own which they wouldn't they could
they couldn't pay bills they couldn't uh
well they could survive on their own
they'd have to have
living human people thralls yeah to act
as their parents to do all their so they
could yeah but they probably couldn't
survive around other vampires because
vampires fought each other
because vampires are [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
they weren't as physically strong
yeah that's true they'd be smaller
they're smaller that would be smaller so
they weren't supposed to you weren't
supposed to do it
but yeah so it's what regardless of
whether she just got turned by Dracula
or was actually Dracula's biological
daughter
um she does not seem to be down with the
whole vampire thing she is like very
very reluctant to be a vampire she just
wants to not be a vampire anymore so
like I said that's kind of like I think
this is the first movie that showed that
like a vampire that didn't want to be a
vampire that you know was maybe maybe
made into one against her will or she
was born like that and she didn't really
want to be that way so the funny thing
about it too is that the actress that
plays her
Gloria Holden uh she wasn't real jazzed
about being in this movie she didn't
want to be in a horror movie
um mainly because she had seen how Bella
Lugosi had gotten Typecast and she was
afraid that if she was in a horror movie
then the same thing was gonna happen to
her and she wouldn't be able to get any
other roles
um but she was eventually like persuaded
to do it and a lot of film Scholars have
pointed out they said you know maybe the
fact that she really didn't want to be
in this movie or didn't want to be in
horror actually like worked in the
character's favor because she comes
across her character comes across as
really kind of like again like reluctant
and like sort of self-loathing which
kind of which is what her character is
supposed to be like so it's like her
real life was like informing the
character which I thought was kind of
interesting because her performance in
this is great yeah and the character
looks great she's she's gorgeous oh yeah
she looks like a statue of Hera or
something uh kind of like a Greek statue
she's not cute
she's very regal regal looking and
um good figure
um they they try to get they try to get
a lot out of it she looks like she
should be on the Mast of a ship yeah so
yeah you know what I mean she looks like
that she looks like the statue of a
Greek goddess she's like the perfect
she's like the perfect kind of like uh
type for this role right she just looks
real serious
you know like something out off of a
monument
but uh yeah it's she looks great yeah
and she's got great like outfits and
stuff yeah
and they they all look they're all kind
of supposed to be real low cut but it's
an optical illusion
but some of it looks like it goes right
down to almost to her navel but it's
just a different they're tricking you
it's just a it's just like flesh colors
flesh colored material it's black and
white you know but um and then uh for
kind of like
um
they do have a cutie in there she's kind
of like the damsel and distressed type
dude hi pookie what's up there and she's
kind of the other way she's uh a real
kind of kind of a boy it it's uh
character a lot of fun Young cute
she's in it and of course there's kind
of like a damn Carmella type it's not
lesbian
it's not blatant
but that's what it is there I mean it's
blatant for 1936. I'll say that like for
now it's I mean nowadays it's like
pretty like tame but for 1936 I was like
whoa I can't believe they got away with
that back and they were aware of it too
because even like in early iterations of
the script actually you're gonna love
this but in one early version of the
script they were actually going to imply
some BDSM action too like they want to
show anything but they were gonna have
her attacking both men and women and she
would be like taking some of her victims
like into her you know Chambers or
whatever and there was going to be like
whips and [ __ ] like on the walls and
like she wasn't gonna use them or touch
them or anything like that but that's
like the implication was going to be
there and I think like the sensors at
the time were like absolutely not we
were not putting that in them we're not
putting that in the movie
um so they were like pretty aware and I
think like even the scene as it came out
because the scene that everybody talks
about is the scene where she picks up a
girl in the street who's like I guess
she's homeless is she homeless I don't
know I guess she's kind of like homeless
or she's like looking for work or
something like that I think that actor's
name is uh Nan Gray and she's also
gorgeous and
um she's basically like you know the
Countess is like she's an artist on the
side when she's not vampiring and uh
vamping the [ __ ] out of here right so
it's got to do something you know
so uh so she picks up this girl and says
hey I'll give you some money if you come
back to my place and like pose for me
and then there's kind of like a pretty
suggestive scene where she's like making
her she's like well I'm just gonna do
your head and shoulders and like makes
her kind of like take her top like down
like that and all this other kind of
stuff and then she's like coming up on
her and yeah like looking at her like
she wants to eat her like but also kind
of sexually and I'm just like damn yeah
it was like that so it's like
you act like you saw that scene
no that was in there was that in there
yeah you don't remember that you don't
remember that scene
yeah were you drunk or something no
I guess that kind of slipped my mind but
I guess that did happen yeah another
stop right yeah because she like pulls
her shirt down like that that's right
you know what I mean so they got that in
there and like when she's like with the
wine and then she's like hypnotizing her
with this thing that's right and she's
like oh yeah yeah that's right you know
what I mean remember now and I was like
whoa late night for 1936. like I said I
mean I I thought that they got away with
that was like pretty yeah amazing
uh mango said it's a very erotic movie
it is and honestly like a lot of it
because I think when we were talking
about it before like you said well it's
almost kind of like a chick flick it's
not I don't know if I'd go that far but
it does have a lot of because there's a
lot of Like Love Triangle stuff and like
a jealousy stuff in it because not only
is the Countess like she comes basically
she comes to London and she steals
Dracula's body
like after it he gets staked and you
know meanwhile Van Helsing is getting
arrested and being like he was a vampire
you know what I mean it's like you can't
like hang me for killing a vampire and
they're like yeah whatever tell us
another one buddy so it's like so he's
going through that situation but then
the Countess comes and steals the body
like Dracula's body and then she Burns
it like ritualistically because she
thinks maybe that will free her from the
vampire curse but it doesn't work so
then she like approaches a friend of Van
helsings who I think he's like a
psychiatrist right like it's like a
hypnotist type thing his name is I think
is Dr Garth and she thinks maybe you
know she's tried everything else
presumably so she's like well maybe
um you know the psychiatrist or maybe he
can hypnotize me out of being a vampire
which okay I mean it's worth a shot
um so but while all that's going on like
they almost kind of like talk about it
like it's an addiction you know what I
mean like like almost like she's trying
to get him to because obviously he
doesn't know she's a vampire fire duh
and he doesn't know that she kills
people but she's basically like you know
I have this thing that I have to do and
I'm trying to stop doing it which is
killing people and he's like well why
don't you just you know see if you can
resist it and then there's these whole
things where she's saying was like well
I tried to resist it but I couldn't
because you know she she drank the blood
of that girl so um so that kind of whole
thing is going on but while that's going
on she also kind of falls in love with
Dr Garth
and the problem too is that Dr Garth has
an assistant no she's a secretary she's
a secretary said well assistant
secretary fires her but not really but
see the thing about it is like the
assistant is also like a baroness so she
doesn't really like need the job yeah
she's like a rich girl yeah and the
there's like a lot of that's kind of
where a lot of the humor because this
movie has a lot of humor in it too she's
a great character because Bride of
Frankenstein was also like kind of funny
so they wanted that same thing as a
matter of fact I think they want a James
whale to direct this as well but he's
like yeah I don't want to do like two
horror movies in a row like more horror
movies in a row so he wanted to go do
something else so they got somebody else
to do it but they wanted to like inject
that same kind of like dark humor like
that have worked so well in Bride of
Frankenstein so a lot of the funny stuff
comes from Dr Garth and his secretary
like because she's a very like modern
like frisky funny kind of woman she's
not putting up with [ __ ] he fires her
and she's basically like ah [ __ ] you
yeah well like I said she's Rich yeah
she doesn't need the money she doesn't
need the money and she I mean she's in
love with him too so when Garth and the
Countess start kind of making or when
the Countess starts like getting into
like Dr Garth
um the secretary girl she starts like
trying to sabotage the whole [ __ ] you
know what I mean like like prank calling
pretty good yeah
like phone games it's like he's on a
date with the Countess he's calling
she's calling him like that [ __ ] with
him impersonating other people yeah yeah
it's funny it's pretty funny yeah she's
on the bed with her feet up in the back
yeah yeah [ __ ] calling from the zoo
like yeah saying stuff about the
elephant seeing pink men or something
like that like can you come like
investigate yeah but he knows it's her
though he's like would you quit [ __ ]
around you know what I mean it's like
that kind of thing so yeah so the two of
them are funny but it's like that's the
whole thing like she's trying to she's
jealous of the Countess and so she's
trying to like intervene but it doesn't
really seem like Dr Garth I don't think
he's like in love with the Countess I
think he's kind of fascinated by her
because she's like hypnotic and she's
kind of weird and he's like wondering
what her deal is but he's kind of I
think like low-key in love with the
secretary and he kind of knows that but
and then they kind of realize it at the
end but so there's a lot of that going
on and then I forgot to mention too that
there's another angle because the
countess also has probably the best one
of the best characters in the movie her
manservant sandor yeah who is like a
dead ringer for Benicio del Toro I think
it looked like like Proto Benicio del
Toro he is [ __ ] great at this I love
interpretation is that he was in love
with her yeah he was well and he wanted
to he was like her servant and I guess
she had promised to make him into a
vampire and then she was like I don't
need you anymore bye you know what I
mean and then he got and for the other
living dude and he went he went [ __ ]
nuts over there and then he got mad but
yeah I thought that was the implication
that he was in love with her yeah I
can't believe she told him that at the
time I was like why'd she just tell her
thrall that well she's well probably
because she's like I'm a vampire [ __ ]
what he's gonna do to me yeah it didn't
no he knew he knew her weaknesses and
stuff well that's the thing like I I
don't know how long they like he had
been her servant or whatever but he's
just like such a great character he's
like so weird looking and he has like
this great voice and the thing about it
is that he's always kind of he's always
like harshing her mellow which I thought
was very it which is also really funny
but like more like dark humor and like
more subtle humor whereas the other two
couple like that that's like more overt
humor like more silly but this one is
kind of more like dark humor because
she's kind of like I'll be alive again
and it'll be wonderful and be like yes
it's all death blah blah blah so he's
like always like [ __ ] in her Cheerios
and it's like super super funny he
didn't want her to be alive right yeah
he's like what's the matter honestly
what's the matter with being they're
gonna be Undead we talking about yeah it
sounds super fun come on but yeah so
that's kind of what happens is that
she decides that she wants the living
psychiatrist Dr Garth
um to be her companion instead of sandor
and so to facilitate this she kidnaps
you know the secretary girl who you know
uh what's who Dr Garth is in love with
yeah and then takes her to Transylvania
liked back to the castle like back to
Dracula's castle where she presumably
lived before and so there's kind of like
then there's like a um you know
confrontation there toward the end but
yeah I mean this this is like a really
good it went in a totally different
direction than the original Dracula but
I think that was a good idea I mean I
think the way that it turned out
um this was really kind of I liked some
of the early ideas that they had for
this yeah I was gonna say I did like
that but but you know what they ended up
with I think was like a really really
good take on the because there was
enough the same about it like it was
obviously in the same universe but there
was you know so there was enough same
that you know if you were going back for
that there was enough vampire action but
then there was like enough different
that it was like its whole other thing
what I would have done is I would have
used some of those original ideas that
you talked about I think I thought those
were good ideas
I would have done some flashback scenes
with Bella in them showing the creation
of her
and how that happened some backstory
that'd have been really cool yeah it
wouldn't have to be that long but it'd
be nice if you got a good 15 minutes you
know yeah of backstory back in the day
why Dracula decided to make a daughter
how he made her
you know was she born a vampire or did
he was she born a living vampire and
then killed her at the age of 30
something so she so she would stay
looking like that the rest of her her
days because if you let her if she was a
living vampire and you let her grow old
she would die of old age eventually and
come up as an old vampire and nobody
wants you wouldn't want that you
wouldn't want to be an old person for
eternity
so you would think if you had a daughter
who was a living vampire you'd have to
kill her at at the best age and then she
would come back
Undead you know maybe that's what
happens maybe that's what happened like
he waited till she was at Peak hotness
yeah and it was okay well Peak power
yeah it would have been in her 30s you
know what I mean type of deal
and uh
so I think that would have been really
cool to have Bella back because he had
done a few huge draw this was [ __ ]
Dracula Dracula and his daughter see
that's well that was the initial idea
that he was supposed to but like I said
because he got killed at the end of the
first one I don't think they were gonna
bring him back I think it was going to
be like a flashback like they were gonna
do like historical and then they were
gonna like bring it up to the modern
that's what I would do but that's the
that was the initial idea I think that
they were well you could do it like you
know when they asked the psychologist
would have asked her like how did you
become a vampire she'd tell the story
and then you go back
yeah you could do a flashback right
that's how I would have done it okay it
would have been a long flashback
basically and then um there's a bunch of
stuff they could have done with this I
don't really the whole thing about
um uh making
Van Helsing a murder suspect I don't
really think they needed to do that
um tracking that when he got staked he
would have turned into powder
according to the other movies there
wouldn't have been a body there and they
would have found which would have been
really handy yeah and then you would
have found uh uh Renfield Renfield dead
and well there was no railing on that
damn yeah that could have been an
accident there's no railing he could
just fall off the stairs he was crazy
nobody would have cared really well yeah
he's crazy fell off the stairs yeah he
probably just jumped off there like like
a lunatic do yeah so there wouldn't have
been any questions asked and uh could
have been that the psychiatrist Guy
meets this vampire he figures out it's a
vampire he calls Van Helsing he's a
friend of his he knows that Van Helsing
has dealt with vampires type of deal
that type of deal I got some vampires oh
I got a Vampire
the headphones you know
or a bit better vampires werewolves oh
you know it just would have been that
[ __ ] Van Helsing would have heard
these [ __ ] stories oh these people
being drained to blood there's a vampire
over that he shows up looking for the
vampire yeah you know you don't really
need to have the the murder accusation
thing that was I thought that just was
kind of like
five minutes ten minutes of wasted film
I didn't you know what I mean yeah I see
what you I like I like that Edition
because you know if you're if you're
positing a thing like I said normally
like when you stake a vampire in real
life normally when you stake a vampire
like they turn to dust right and I think
even in the book maybe he turned it up
yeah I remember but yeah so um so that
wouldn't happen but like if you're
positing a universe where you stake the
vampire and then he just lays there all
staked and dead again
um yeah you're gonna you're gonna run
into problems before the Advent of like
you know forensic science or anything
that says hey this person's been dead
500 years it's like yeah you're gonna be
like a murderer suspect I thought the
murder suspect angle was more like
filler more than anything else most of
the material was just kind of a filler
to flesh it out and it would have been
better to get rid of that and then put
more Dracula time in there with Bella
more Dracula time and more and more like
action things actually happen and maybe
like another murder scene another uh
yeah
they just use that as filler if you ask
me well and yeah now that you now that
you say it it doesn't really end up I
think it's weird because it wasn't an
important story element well yeah it's
like I think it was only in there so
it's like we could reiterate like what
vampires are and how they work and
everything like that because you have to
think this is like the 1930s and also it
had been five years since the first film
so it's not like you know it's not like
nowadays where you can binge like you
know a whole series or something like
that like in one night so you don't have
to like remember [ __ ] from like five
years ago yeah but so maybe that's what
it was they were trying to like catch
everyone up and they thought that that
would be a good way to do it they always
underestimated people's intelligence
well they did I know yeah I wouldn't
have explained [ __ ] I would have just
shown it to them and [ __ ] let them
wonder what the [ __ ] happened well
that's just what vampires do you know
what I mean somebody else later on you
you could have Van Helsing there to go
yeah what happens is vampires tend to do
this and that which explains it a little
bit later yeah [ __ ] like that
and I would have thought like because
Dracula was such a big hit and a lot of
people had read the novel too or seen it
on stage people probably so you think
that like you know that Eve that even
back then yeah all of the vampire tropes
would have been pretty well established
I imagine they were but like you said I
kind of feel like up until and I kind of
feel like this happened up until thank
you Jeff Earhart thank you very much
what is it it's it's a little guy going
incredible okay
I kind of feel like up until maybe even
the 1960s I feel like a lot of movies
not all of them obviously but a lot of
movies were they kind of aired on the
side of over explaining everything like
when there was [ __ ] that obviously like
most people probably would have known
and they didn't need to explain I think
it was filler I think maybe I think they
just needed dialogue yeah to fill the
movie out which that was the problem
with these things don't make a movie
unless you can afford to shoot it
you know what I mean well unless you
[ __ ] anxious you know an hour hour
and a half versus worth of material yeah
shoot action stuff show don't tell
that's just a sign of a good movie and
they did do that kind of stuff in in the
30s they they showed look at King Kong
King Kong [ __ ] showed you [ __ ] it
didn't really talk about it
yeah it didn't explain [ __ ] why there
were [ __ ] dinosaurs on the island it
didn't really look there's one star it
just are I didn't explain why they're
why [ __ ] Kong was so big it just it
just he was [ __ ] huge he didn't
explain why they were down you know uh
tribes men on their whole with a big
wall holding him back you know you're
just looked at it and went oh [ __ ] you
you made up your own explanations
you know well I mean it was pretty like
yeah you could the implication was you
know the implications were pretty clear
I guess and it was like a prehistoric
[ __ ] island of [ __ ] where things
got [ __ ] big you know
giant dinosaurs and giant gorillas and
giant walls and hey man even though it's
funny because in real life from an
evolutionary standpoint um animals that
evolve on Islands tend to be much
smaller than their Mainland counterparts
not bigger yeah and uh and which makes
sense and [ __ ] primates are not from
the dinosaur era no
a lot a long time later
well yeah but I kind of feel like most
people just like whatever it was yes it
was a long time ago and it was big
well and the thing about it too with
King Kong they were just probably like
kids love dinosaurs we're gonna put
dinosaurs in there too who cares if like
dinosaurs living at the same time there
were some there were some deleted scenes
that were never put in there where Kong
fights a giant spider I think there's
some of that still around but yeah I've
seen clips of it but I don't it's in
kind of shitty conditions yeah evidently
they cut it out it was hard to do and I
I think the explanation was is they
thought it would upset people too much
that big old spider but I don't know but
it was a huge [ __ ] spider they all
fighting it
I'd like to have seen that
Pat says don't forget oh God the wild
wild world of Batwoman also known as she
was a hippie vampire better yet on
second thought do forget it because it
really really sucks bad I agree it is a
terrible terrible movie however it made
a very entertaining Mystery Science
Theater episode
it look yeah it was kind of like they
were vampires but also superheroes
and it was one of the weirdest movies
ever made really weird sounds like
something came out of Turkey
it was almost that bad it was almost
that quality even though I'm pretty sure
it was an American movie okay but you've
probably seen it because I think I
watched the MST episode not too long ago
it's an awful awful movie yeah but like
the MST episode is like super turkey had
a hard time accepting the Spider-Man and
Batman were good guys they just couldn't
accept that not looking those not
looking that way you know this will not
stand they must be villains
[Laughter]
uh Pat says producers still
underestimate people's intelligence they
do but I don't think it's to the same
extent as because man sometimes I'll
watch movies and like I said it's not
across the board because I've seen
movies from the 40s and 50s that you
know left a lot to your imagination or
left you to figure [ __ ] out on your own
but I kind of feel like a lot of movies
from like pre-1960s that were meant for
like a mass audience like a mainstream
audience would just oh just explain the
[ __ ] out of everything like you'd have
to have these scenes where like all
these dudes were like sitting around
talking in a room explaining like really
really simple [ __ ] yeah
um you know which I'm just like yeah
everybody here has been to sixth grade
we know all this stuff I have a feeling
that the people knew that back then what
they were expecting that's what I'm
saying I don't think that it was a kind
of a case where everyone was dumb back
then they don't know that they knew yeah
I think they did know it was just filler
yeah you know yeah
mango says if you want a movie with no
filler then watch House of Dracula in
the Universal horror series just gets on
with it and done and dusted in just over
an hour what year is that house address
yeah House of Dracula think of that yeah
like I said we're gonna have to like
watch more you know because there's so
many that I miss I kind of feel like
this one because it started
um you know the the universal the first
wave because they came in waves kinda
you know what I mean yeah so the first
wave started in 1931 obviously with
Dracula and then I feel like this movie
in 1936 this was kind of like the end of
the first wave because after this they
still made them but it wasn't they
weren't quite as popular and this movie
actually did pretty well it obviously
didn't do as well as the original
Dracula but it did get like decent
reviews and it did like do pretty good
at the box office I put this movie
reminded me a lot of cat people the
original cat people but I put it above
cat people I think it's better than cat
people cat people had some slow parts to
it yeah and this one doesn't really I
mean yeah and I love cat people but um
the Val Luton movie from the 40s
um but yeah it does have some like slow
bits to it and it's not and it's only
barely horror I feel like this one has a
lot more and honestly cat people is a
little bit more Noir yeah uh whereas
this one is a lot more Gothic yeah this
one is like it's this one
and this one is more I I wouldn't say
it's like overtly a horror movie but it
does have a lot more horror elements and
a lot more Gothic elements than like cat
people did an erotic elements too that's
bow erotic you see where you see where
hammer has got some of their inspiration
they saw it was if they could do that we
can beat that we'll show cleavage yeah
you know a lot of it well yeah because
by the time the hammer color and they're
like yeah okay by the time the 60s
rolled around you could say you could
show that [ __ ] you're like not getting
in trouble Carmella was great I don't
know I think that was Hammer wasn't it
carmilla well there's been a lot of
different versions of Carmella
the one that I liked I think was Hammer
well there was a version but it wasn't
called carmilla though it was called
um it wasn't it dark was it Daughters of
Darkness was that hammer no I can't
remember okay but I know that there was
one called Daughters of Darkness that
was based there's been like a lot that
were based on carmilla though but I
don't know there have been some that
were called carmilla but that's a pretty
yeah it's just funny to think that that
story is so old yeah
um you know and but they've made so many
and honestly I think too
there's a movie called Nadia and I can't
remember what year it came out I want to
say it was the 90s I remember seeing it
but I think it's kind of like a low-key
remake of Dracula's daughter you know
what I mean so I haven't seen it in a
long time so I don't remember how
similar it is but I mean this like I
said this was kind of like the best yeah
they could have gone in a different
direction with it but like with what
they had I think this was actually kind
of like a really cool take on the
Dracula Mythos they're still vampires in
it it still had Van Helsing it still had
all that kind of stuff but it's its own
thing honestly even though it takes
place like right after the original
Dracula this could be a standalone I
mean you could watch this without having
seen Dracula it doesn't really it
doesn't really matter I mean I think
that it is cool like to watch them both
back to back but you don't need to have
seen the original one to enjoy this one
it kind of it's It's its own contained
story even though like a couple of the
characters over lap uh mango said Hammer
made a few from that story uh lust for a
vampire being one uh then there was
vampire lovers yeah vampire lovers I
think is the one yeah that I'm thinking
of yeah that was the 70s did we review
that I kind of feel like we did it was a
long time ago
what was the one with the um
the two twins
what twins of evil twins of evil that
was good too which the two blonde girls
yeah the Playboy bunnies yeah they were
yeah that was Hammer yeah that was that
was a good movie yeah we reviewed that
one because I think we made the joke
back then it's like yeah they were twins
but also their boobs were twins yeah
and it's just like the first one of the
very first shots of the movie is just
like move down below and I was like yep
that's Hammer all right
the the British were great scientists
they were great professors of bubology
where they understood the the the
science
did they get people in the [ __ ]
theater all right yeah what they were
doing
I mean America understood very much we
liked it
yeah we we see your game we like that
blood and boobies oh [ __ ] England had
[ __ ]
Bodacious [ __ ] boob gang man back in
the day I don't know if they're still
like that but [ __ ] man
[ __ ] Benny Hill whatever those
[ __ ] yeah they used to show that on
PBS yeah for those of you in the UK yeah
they used to yeah they showed it on
public television yeah they showed like
a lot of British stuff they said like
Benny Hill are you being served yeah but
yeah I used to see Benny Hill like in
the 70s like when I was a kid when I was
a little kid Benny Hill made sure that
there was gonna be some hot women on the
down and they and they would be running
around running around and [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the bathroom he got under a lot of
attack people said well he must be some
kind of sexist this everybody said he
was he was just a quiet guy mostly just
living at home lived modestly you know
for his income and I'm just a regular
guy he evidently was really upset about
these [ __ ] attacks I think it's
terrible he was just comedian you know
yeah and that was very much in the
Zeitgeist at the time like that was kind
of like you know the guy chasing the
secretary around the desk and her boobs
bouncing and stuff everybody was you
were supposed to laugh at it it was it
was so everybody was doing it yeah it
was just yeah it was just silly you know
what I mean yeah if you did it like
serious okay that might be problematic
but yeah it was just kind of like no the
joke was always on the man yeah always
on the man yeah the joke wasn't on the
women it was on the men but what you
know dogs they were yeah and then how
you know yeah that's what they were
women were [ __ ] that's what they were
lampooning yeah that women kind of
dominated men in a way well and then
it's like look what we have to put up
with because
we can't even get any workshops these
[ __ ] keep chasing us around the
desk all day long yeah it's like Jesus
Christ
um
uh mango says the Collinson twins that's
who was in twins I met them yeah really
okay were they nice they were cute man
they were cute back then in the day yes
man I love Hammer movies that's what we
probably should do more Hammer movies
yeah like after we get through with like
the universal costumes are real good the
sets were good especially once it
started getting in the late 60s and the
70s they looked really good
yeah I mean I think we did it was just
gonna be hot boobage in there man yeah
to have that girl who that British
actress that was in in the old Excalibur
she would show up in him every now and
then she was smoking hot too what was
that woman's name blood
she played she played the Sorceress
[ __ ] morgada right wasn't it well
that was Helen Mirren Helen Mirren yeah
I didn't remember Helen Mirren being in
anything
yeah she was in some Hammer flicks
yeah if I remember correctly she was the
one that played uh you know the one that
was I think it was Morgana was her name
wouldn't it yeah something like that it
was Arthur's
half-sister who ended up becoming the
Sorceress
yeah she was cute
with the fish nets and [ __ ] yeah Proto
goth kind of outfit they had around
a lot of goth girls wore that yeah mango
said nope she was not in Hammer that's
what I thought no I thought she was now
she was in one of those British she's
been in [ __ ] tons she was in [ __ ] tons
of British movies TV shows and
everything like that but she wasn't in
any camera okay now she was in some
British British horror movie that I
thought was her
I've seen her in tons of stuff but I
don't remember her being in any Hammer
movies no and I know that there's like a
[ __ ] out of camera movies and I
haven't seen them all but I'm pretty
sure that she was you better I just got
to confuse somebody else I think that's
probably why yeah Pat said I remember
seeing a black and white female vampire
movie in the theater was that Nadia it
might have been because I think Nadia
was black and white uh speaking of cool
modern black and white female vampire
movies recommend the addiction yeah
that's also good without this one with
Lily Taylor I think I remember seeing
that one and then somebody mentioned uh
a girl walks home alone at night which
was also another vampire movie and that
was also very good also black and white
matter of fact
um yeah Mega said they were very nice
ladies took time to answer questions and
have a drink with you too
how old were they when you when you met
them just out of curiosity
because that is what did twins of you
will come out 1972.
I feel like it was early 70s we should
probably do more Hammer like I said I
remember we did fairly recently we did
the first Christopher Lee
Dracula movie which in UK is just called
Dracula but over here is called Horror
of Dracula that was 1958 and I remember
you not loving it because you're like
well this hasn't really you know got up
to the standard I do kind of feel like
the the Dracula movies got better later
on although although I do love the end
of
quarter of Dracula though
Pat Hatfield said Tom's got it exactly I
don't know exactly what he's talking
about he must be talking about hammer
and boobs with the boobs must be yeah
Clarity dude says uh we need a t-shirt
saying let me see your Hammer boobs yeah
Zach just got here hello what did I miss
pretty much the whole show
[Laughter]
mango said they were in their early 50s
as I recall and they looked stunning hmm
I'd be curious what they are they still
around maybe in their 70s now are they I
guess but you know that doesn't mean
anything it would have been uh late
teens early 20s in the 70s which would
put them in their 70s now yeah okay
yeah because I'm pretty sure twins of
evil was early 70s
uh Mark says I'm listening to Vampire
Lestat on audiobook I'd love to see it
on screen yeah I mean you know I kind of
always wish they had done like the movie
trilogy
good back in the old days like the first
one was Interview with the Vampire was
good but then they did Queen of the
Damned and it's like they didn't even do
Lestat they just kind of like tried to
cram list at into the Queen of the
Damned and it's like those are two big
huge chunkers yeah of novels and it's
like there was just too much they took
out and Queen of the Damned that book is
not moviable
there's a lot I can't see how you could
really make that book into a movie
that would be coherent
the stuff that was in that movie
there's so much [ __ ] in the book that
was left out like I said anything like
that has just got to be a series I don't
even know what you're thinking like
attempting to turn it into a movie well
a lot of that book is like things that
Lestat remembered that too you know what
I mean so how do you make that in a
movie you know
because if I remember correctly some of
that book he's basically
narrating a lot of it
am I am I remember that correctly I
don't know it's been a long time since I
wrote yeah it's in here she's
remembering things that he did a long
time ago and remembering who what
vampire he made and remembering uh how
he was how
uh well actually that was vampire the
stat is where he's remembering how he
got made and
how that how that [ __ ] Magnus bit him
it was a little [ __ ] sorcerer
it's just it's just it was just Queen of
the Damned I don't remember if he
narrates that or not but I haven't read
it in so long
yeah one of these days I wanted to sit
down and read all of those again because
I haven't read them in years and years
just go through them things man I have
them somewhere you know what I don't
think have they ever made her like witch
books into a series or movies or
anything some of those were pretty good
another good one was MIM knock the devil
yeah I liked that one too yeah and the
stats in that
um then and then there's uh tale of the
body body Thief that was great too I
liked that one yeah the stats in that
one it's about a dude who learned how to
actually project and then steal other
people's
bodies as you do yeah and he wanted to
steal the stats about it because he
wanted to be a vampire
he's like ooh that's a good one yeah
which you know that's understandable
right and having having had a [ __ ]
spontaneous Obe before
I could see how that might be plausible
that you might be able to steal somebody
else's body
and make off with it yeah now he was
able to steal with a person who was in
Catatonia remember it was it was a
comatose kind of person he stole that
body from a
a hospital yeah and that's how he left
his body behind and got a new one I
forgot why he left his original body
behind if he was sick or he was
imprisoned or something he needed a new
body yeah he could jump from one body to
the next using astral projection
possible Mark says the witch novels are
made into a series it's coming to AMC in
the next month or so yeah it was like I
okay it surprised me it took this long
because those books have been out
forever it was last year too but I don't
remember
I remember I remember that one but you
know okay yeah I don't remember if I
read that one which one was that one
about [ __ ] wasn't that about the
Egyptians I don't remember or it's been
such a long time or yes something I
forgot what that was about all right I
don't maybe I didn't read that one maybe
I just remembered the title I read it
but I don't remember which one it was
right Zach says to be honest I think
Lestat is Tom Cruise's best role from an
acting perspective I think it is like I
actually believe him in his least
believable part yeah yeah I think yeah
one of his I think yeah well he does
really good as Ethan Hunt too yeah and
uh but we've said this before I think
he's better when he's a villain or like
he plays an [ __ ] like I guess he was
great in Magnolia because he was a dick
in that too yeah
um let's see uh and the stat was a dick
but he was kind of lovable yeah he was a
lovable yeah lovable dick he was just
arrogant as [ __ ] man Tom crew is perfect
for that
yeah
that's what I mean that was like good
cast yeah
um Hugo says Jenny have you seen near
dark yes matter of fact I've seen it
several times and we did a review of it
not too long ago right that was the one
with Bill paxter uh yeah yeah Bill
Paxton and like within uh Lance
Hendrickson and they were all like a
vampire the vampire gang you know what I
mean it was kind of like a western type
thing you remember that yeah okay then
Richard Brown said poppy Z bright yeah I
remember yeah they're um
yeah I really liked uh drawing blood
lost souls that was the first one I
think she's a man now wouldn't she yeah
she's trans yeah so she I can't remember
what her name she changed her name yeah
but
um yeah they like
Exquisite corpse is [ __ ] up too
whichever it's not a vampire novel it's
about serial killers but that's one of
the most [ __ ] up things I've ever read
but it's great it's great but it's
really really [ __ ] up
really [ __ ] up all right so um are we
ready to call it a day all right so
thanks everybody for dropping by listen
to us talk about Universal we'll
probably do some more Universal monsters
and maybe some Hammer like uh going
forward because yeah we're having a good
time like watching these old ones and
tomorrow night is our main show and I'm
kind of excited about this one uh
because we're gonna be talking about the
Lisa McPherson yeah case Okay the Church
of Scientology I'm ready for that one
and the Lisa McPherson death yeah I'm
ready for that so we're gonna talk about
that one so so we might be getting sued
it might be exciting
maybe not we've done like other shows
about scientology
doing that well right so they're
evidently having some problems right now
so we'll see yeah well I don't think
they'd be coming after us mate
I mean but you know if they did maybe
we'd get more attention but maybe not
because it's like I don't know nobody
I'd live stream that [ __ ] yeah the
squirrel Busters come up to the [ __ ]
house or the camera oh my God that'd be
hilarious those Tech those Tech the
tactics that they used in the past don't
work anymore so they don't use them yeah
uh yeah Zach said Oh yay I mean Boo for
Lisa but still yeah yeah I think it'll
be a good show and like I said I have
like a little bit of a personal
connection there because I know some of
the people that uh that were at that
trial because they knew her she worked
at the same company that I worked at
when I lived in there except like
several years earlier
so yeah that should be fun so you guys
we'll see you again tomorrow have a good
rest of your evening and we'll see you
again tomorrow bye